do you still have the fantasy factor
is that no no no i and you know for
that that whole thing was ultimately i
was so sick of [ __ ] shooting tv in my
house
yeah and was so [ __ ] sick of people
coming to my house all the time you know
and
and and it being in that zone but what i
what i realized is god i just made so
much money
from this platform and you know they
wanted me to do a fourth season
of robin big but at that point me and
him were like beefing so hard
uh you know mainly on this idea that
we felt kind of bound to each other and
lost our sort of identities right like
and
and neither of us wanted to do the show
anymore but
they had offered me at that time to give
you context 125 000 an episode
to either do another season of robin big
or do my own show
and i'm i was like [ __ ] i don't want to
do my own show
and but then i realized man quit being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] man like
you just go uh do another show so i
wrote the concept
uh of uh called it fantasy life but then
i
then i realized like no i need to be
like a get a building and become like
willy wonka
and i'm gonna call that [ __ ] the fantasy
factory but i would only do it
if they also gave me my integration
rights
so i could sell the platform
um when i did it so then i was able to
do deals with like chevy and microsoft
and used the actual platform
to sell the app advertising on which
really blew everything up to like an
even crazier level wow
let me take you back to the other you
said they offered 125
000 an episode how much of that is
talent fee
versus producer fee because everyone
says at that time
25 of it was producer right like because
back then you know like producer was
still
for me at least in that standpoint
before i built super jacket
producer was more what they gave us as
talent you know what i'm saying like
where they would just because what did
what did you get at the peak of wild
boys
oh my god we had the same from the whole
[ __ ] time pontius and i each got 15
grand an episode
right so it's like like think how nuts
that was
like and it was like damn [ __ ] it i'm
gonna do and i was like
[ __ ] it like i spent 750
g's to build out the fantasy factory and
then
midway through that season they were
like this [ __ ] sucks
we're not even gonna air this [ __ ] and
i'm like god damn it
what the [ __ ] like and
what's up what was the rent like 30
grand a month
30 35 grand a month just to like have
that place you know what i mean and then
i [ __ ] you know
spent i built i it was [ __ ] balls to
the wall no
like i built the place completely out
[ __ ] skatepark
full concrete [ __ ] skatepark in a
building you know what i mean like
uh super over the top but they it was
only
they tried to make it robin big with my
cousin drama
rather than integrating all the people
that were in the
business side of my business my manager
and
and and sort of my my lawyer and artist
and everyone involved in my companies
and when i went back and looked at some
of the cuts the very first cuts where it
integrated all of them
like we re-pitched the shows like this
is a group
not just me and my cousin we gotta quit
trying to make robin big
and that's when it became um what it
became but that's now now i'm doing
[ __ ] stunts
right because i was never a stunt guy
i'm a business guy but i wrote a bowl
in robin big and started to open up the
juice a little bit
right and then in that first episode
uh tremaine i was making a joke about
getting attacked by a shark and tremaine
was like oh i got a place that'll do it
in the bahamas
and so next thing you know i'm [ __ ]
in a chain suit in the [ __ ]
60 feet under [ __ ] water with a
[ __ ] piece of tuna on my arm
thinking like do i really want to
[ __ ] lose function over my arm this
isn't even funny
yeah i feel like you got to be careful
what you say around jeff tremaine
is that true i don't was that the blue
it was kind of like the blue cove or the
blue lagoon or whatever yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah what is that yeah yeah we
went through them
yeah it sounded so funny yeah it's
sharks man sharks have been my thing
hey you're right they're not even
[ __ ] funny
yeah dude